We are expecting our first eight,
Evan says,
we are expecting our first
child in May a daughter.
Any specific,
any advice specific to raising daughters?
Well,
congratulations first,
so that's great.
Um,
okay.
Let's see.
I'm just thinking about my
daughter and specific advice.
I would say don't be afraid to support
her masculine and feminine sides,
you know,
and so the feminine side is
you'll find little girls.
Now,
not all little girls because some
are more masculine than others,
but let's say you have a
more feminine little girl.
She's going to like to dress up and
she's going to like to put on jewelry.
It's amazing how much of that stuff
seems to be implicit or a Nate,
you know,
and that can be really supported.
But then by the same token,
it's nice to wrestle with your little
girl kids and little kids really like
rough and tumble play into and to,
you know,
encourage her to be
courageous and forthright.
And so if you're lucky you can,
you can support her in both elements
of her personality and that would be a
really good thing to do.
So
don't let her wrap.
Are you around her little finger either?
That's another thing too.